heures on en a beaucoup parlé
dernièrement après plusieurs suicides on
estime qu'un arrêt maladie sur quatre de
plus de deux mois serait dû à des
problèmes psychosociaux
d'après les spécialistes le travail est
moins pénible physiquement qu'avant mais
la notion de performance beaucoup plus
présente enquête perrine bonnet frédéric
capron longtemps la dureté du travail a
été associé à ces d'image l'effort et la
souffrance physique
aujourd'hui c'est la reconnaissance
d'une autre souffrance moins visible
celle là le stress yannick penyas a
passé 25 ans de sa vie sur les routes de
france un métier qu'il aime mais en
janvier dernier il change de patron
tout bascule on se fout de l'heure à
laquelle j'ai terminé la veille par
exemple soient définies à 20h30 wire
savais que je devais avoir une visite
chez un médecin dans la semaine un
meilleur fini à 20h30 qui m'a fait
reprendre 2 heures du matin insomnie
dépression
le stress provoque même chez lui des
réactions cutanées pour lui au niveau
des coûts de nos débuts ne me parlez pas
du tout de ce qui se passait au sel de
son travail tout ça donc il rentre à la
maison on n'est même pas de l'adresse la
parole parce que oui s'énerver mais on
comprenait pas vraiment ce qui se
passait bon je vais l'avouer vraiment
farmer s'est pas engagé une en bio ne
plus être rejoints par ceux de la maison
puis après j'ai réfléchi suicides le mot
résonne encore au technocentre de
renault devenu bien malgré lui un
symbole l'an dernier en l'espace de
quatre mois trois salariés mettre fin à
leurs jours et tout récemment il ya deux
semaines un employé d'un sous-traitant
de renault se donne lui aussi la mort le
lien avec le stress professionnel n'est
pas établi mais ce nouveau drame rabbit
colère et d'où leur côté syndicats
personne n'est prêt à voir quelqu'un se
suicider ça c'est clair
donc vous en avez un on se pose déjà des
questions vous en avez deux on se pose
encore plus de questions qui est comme
ça jusqu'à 4 voyez donc là non on ne
peut pas on ne peut pas accepter ça pour
eux c'est l'esprit d'entreprise qui est
en cause auparavant les ateliers et
autres on est une famille on savait
qu'en la personne était pas le matin en
province téléphone on appelait on se
renseignait aujourd'hui ce [ __ ] et ce
alors ils seront en ligne
aujourd'hui le discours de la direction
s'est rapproché de celui des syndicats
c'est un rappel à l'ordre extrêmement
fort il faut revenir à ce que
j'appellerais des fondamentaux du
management la proximité l'écoutent la
solidarité alors depuis un an
l'entreprise applique un plan anti
stress
les bureaux ouvrent désormais entre 7h
et 20h 30 au lieu de 5h30 à 22h30
auparavant les réunions doivent se tenir
à des horaires raisonnable pas avant 8
heures pas après 18 heures les managers
doivent empêcher les salariés d'emporter
du travail à domicile et veiller à ce
qu'ils prennent une pause déjeuner d'une
heure renault tente ainsi de répondre à
une situation d'urgence
mais cette épidémie du stress a gagné en
profondeur le monde de l'entreprise ce
psychanalyste reçoit une dizaine de
salariés par semaine les symptômes sont
souvent les mêmes revues journaux pas
j'ai vu les personnes qui était déjà en
arrêt de travail depuis un an
depuis un an à savoir que certaines
techniques de management
je crois qu'il faut le dire qui coûte
une certaine somme aux caisses
d'assurance maladie le stress au travail
en effet un coût humain bien sûr
économies pour l'assurance maladie
près de 50 milliards d'euros